deformidad es un rescate inesperado en
el corazón del bosque polaco los
miembros de esta ong descubrieron a
estos dos migrantes con hipotermia tras
varios días viviendo en la intemperie a
3 grados celsius
los encontramos en el bosque estaban en
estado crítico y no podíamos
comunicarnos con ellos es imposible
preguntarles qué ha pasado solo dieron
sus nombres
exordio names una vez les prestaron los
primeros auxilios los dos hermanos de 40
años fueron trasladados al hospital
desde el comienzo de la crisis han
muerto al menos una docena de migrantes
el domingo las autoridades bielorrusas
publicaron estas imágenes de cientos de
migrantes dirigiéndose a la frontera en
el lugar los militares polacos les
esperaban con una orden clara las
fronteras polacas permanecerán cerradas
y seguras no se permite cruzar sin los
documentos necesarios las fuerzas de los
rusas se están utilizando entre minsk y
varsovia actualmente se libra una guerra
de comunicación la televisión estatal
difundió esta cima de la cruz roja'
bielorrusa distribuyendo alimentos a los
migrantes
suscripción todos los niños han recibido
alimentos como pueden ver vienen con sus
madres a recibir bolsas de comida para
adultos y niños
al otro lado de la alambrada los polacos
tienen en la polémica función de impedir
el paso de la gente mientras que los
guardias bien los rusos deben impedir
cualquier retorno de los migrantes a
minsk mientras miles de personas están
acorraladas en la frontera bruselas
denuncia una manipulación de belarús y
rusia para presionar a la unión europea
por su parte el presidente putin rechazó
estas acusaciones e instó a los europeos
a resolver sus diferencias directamente
con minsk